[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight never meet your heroes
that's how the saying goes they'll only
disappoint you
well that's true by the way as Democrats
across the country learned the hard way
today former Special Counsel Robert
Muller testified on Capitol Hill this
morning if you watch the other cable
channels you're probably accustomed to
thinking of Robert Muller as a kind of
progressive superhero sent here from on
high to do battle with the diabolical
mr. orange on behalf of the forces of
light and justice Hollywood literally
produced a comic book about Robert
Muller that's how convinced they were of
his power and goodness single-handedly
Robert Muller was going to save America
and then came the long sad spectacle of
today here's the actual Robert Muller
clock without his cape and mask
squirming under the cold light of
television cameras when discussing the
June 2016
Trump Tower meeting you reference quote
the firm that produced steel reporting
unquote the name of that firm was fusion
GPS is that correct and you're on page
103 when I was three that's correct
volume two I'm not familiar with that
it's not it's not a trick question I
mean it was fusion GPS not familiar with
fusion GPS well it turns out that if
you're watching this show right now you
almost certainly know more about the
Russia investigation than the man who
led the Russia investigation you know
that fusion GPS is the Democratic Oppo
firm that paid Christopher Steele to
produce the Trump dossier fusion GPS is
the reason we're talking about Russia
right now
in fact fusion GPS is the reason we had
a Muller investigation in the first
place but of course you knew that
because you're paying attention somehow
Robert Muller himself did not know that
what does that say about Robert Muller
well this isn't a medical program so
we're not going to speculate about it
well we can say for certain though is
that Robert Muller never should have
been testifying before Congress today he
didn't want to come
he came because Democrats forced him
they knew his condition they were happy
to exploit him anyway and they did to
the left the individual is always far
less important than the mission and the
mission never changes
acquiring political power watch the
congenitally shameless Jerry Nadler of
New York use Muller as a kind of human
backboard throw the question get it back
the report did not conclude that he did
not commit obstruction of justice is
that correct that is correct
and what about total exoneration did you
actually totally exonerate the president
no now in fact your reports expressly
states that it does not exonerate the
president it does Muller did not
exonerate the president that was the
headline on CNN today of course it was
the headline and that was the point of
asking the question in the first place
to create a headline unmentioned was the
fact that prosecutors don't exonerate
anyone ever prosecutors charged people
with crimes or they don't that's the
full scope of their power only god
exonerates the whole thing was a
dishonest word game moments later in
fact Robert Millar conceded that his was
the first Justice Department
investigation in history to claim that
it's unindicted subject was not
exonerated can you give me the example
other than Donald Trump where the
Justice Department determined that an
investigated person was not exonerated
because their innocence was not
conclusively determined okay well you
can't time is short I've got five
minutes let's just leave it it you can't
find it because I'll tell you why it
doesn't exist that was probably the high
point of the day for everyone everyone
participating everyone watching at home
most of the rest of the time it was
depressing to watch Muller seemed deeply
confused at times confused about why he
was there repeatedly he struggled to
hear the questions he was being asked
when he did hear them his answers often
revealed he was not familiar at all with
the report that bears his name collusion
and conspiracy are essentially
synonymous terms correct know if no on
page 180 of Volume one of your report
you wrote as defined in legal
dictionaries
illusion is largely synonymous with
conspiracy as that crime is set forth in
the general federal conspiracy statute
18 USC 371 I'm reading your report sir
is it yes or no answer h1 80 page 180
volume 1 this was from your report
correct and I leave it with the report
so the report says yes they are
synonymous hopefully for finally out of
your own report we can put to bed the
collusion and conspiracy it went on like
this for more than six excruciating
hours we hope you were doing something
else today we can tell you though that
over 200 times well are simply declined
to answer the question at all repeatedly
he said that critical questions central
to the Russian investigation weren't in
his purview do you have any basis as you
sit here today to believe that steel was
lying as I said before I say again it's
not my purview others are investigating
what you so it's not rest view to look
into whether or not Steel's line it's
not your purview to look into whether or
not anti-trump Russians are lying to
steel and it's not your purview to look
at whether or not Glenn Simpson was
meeting with the Russians the day before
and the day after you write 3,500 words
about the Trump campaign meeting so
given what we've already said about mr.
melih we don't want to be cruel here but
we also want to be clear about what he's
indicating Muller just told us that he
doesn't know if Christopher steel is
lying about the basis of the entire
Russia investigation nope he doesn't
know and by the way he doesn't care
keep in mind Robert Muller is the very
same man who as of right now he's trying
to send Roger stone to prison for the
rest of his life for telling minor and
totally irrelevant lies allegedly that
hurt no one but he doesn't care to know
if Christopher steel is lying about the
most important question in the
investigation which he's dedicated two
and a half years of his life it's tough
to shake your faith actually if you
think about it for a minute by the end
of the day even partisan Democrats had
to admit that Miller's testimony had
been a complete debacle as they were
using him for clarity he'd somehow fog
it up but he would do certain things and
so look on optics this was a disaster
she was the ball in
no pictures over today he was a witness
and he frankly wasn't a really good
witness because he declined to answer my
my count over a hundred times I thought
he was boring I thought in some cases he
was sort of evasive I thought it really
was in a very ineffective defense of his
own work look from the Democratic
perspective to me so far it's been a bit
of a bust a lot of Democrats in
particular used the D word and branded
this a disaster early on at the very
least we now know the truth about Robert
Muller a mysterious prosecutor with
unchecked power revealed at last to be a
daft old man blinking in the sunlight
once his curtain was torn away it was a
sad coda to the long and ridiculous
Russia saga an absurd story for certain
but not a harmless story hardly this
years-long charade deeply hurt this
country it corrupted our most important
institutions it divided our people but
worst of all it distracted all of us
from our real problems which are legion
get in the car tomorrow morning and
drive five hours in any direction in
this country stop frequently look around
how's America doing do you think now
remember that all the sadness you just
saw on your drive that drug zombies and
the homeless people the payday loan
places the boarded up buildings all the
slow-motion disasters unfolding
unmistakeably all around us all of that
has been completely ignored for years in
favor of some stupid invented story
about Russian spies that never even made
sense and didn't even happen
a ruling class did that they did that to
you as a distraction they do not deserve
to rule that much is clear